Encuentra a "a" y verifica tu respuesta.
Ok y tenemos aquí que "a" más 5 es igual a 54.
¿Y eso qué es lo que quiere decir?
Quiere decir que aquí tenemos un número
o una variable que a la hora de que le sumamos
5, nos queda 54 y tal vez puedes hacer esto
muy rápidamente en tu cabeza,
pero lo que vamos a hacer en este video es hacerlo de
una forma sistemática
porque eso nos va a servir cuando nos encontremos con problemas un poco más complicados.
Y si lo que queremos es encontrar a "a", tenemos
una ecuación que tiene a la variable, bueno a la letra "a"
entonces lo que queremos es hacer que
esta "a" se quede solita,
completamente solita del lado izquierdo del igual, esa es la forma más fácil de encontrar a "a".
Y para hacer eso, pues lo único que tenemos que
hacer es deshacernos de este más 5
y hay una forma muy fácil de deshacernos de ese
más 5 y eso es simplemente restándole 5. Ok.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque 5 menos 5 es 0, entonces tenemos
aquí "a" más 0 que es simplemente "a", cierto...
Bueno, pero queremos que se preserve esta
igualdad entonces todo lo que le hagamos del
lado izquierdo del igual, se lo tenemos que
hacer al lado derecho del igual,
ok, entonces aquí tenemos 54 y también le tenemos que restar 5 por acá.
Y entonces lo que nos queda es "a" más 5
menos 5, es igual a "a" más 0
y aquí lo que tenemos es 54 menos 5, que eso es 49.
¡Y listo!
entonces ya terminamos, "a" es igual a 49, ok.
Esta es la respuesta, ya encontramos a "a" y ahora lo único que nos falta es verificar la respuesta.
Ok, entonces para verificar nuestra respuesta
lo que tenemos que hacer es verificar que
en efecto, si "a" es igual a 49, entonces
"a" más 5 es igual a 54.
Ok, tenemos que ver que 49, porque "a" es
igual a 49 más 5 es igual a 54.
49 más 5 es 54.
Y 54 pues sigue siendo 54.
Entonces si se da esta igualdad,
ok. ¡Y ya terminamos!